hello everyone this is GM Josh Fidel so
today I'm gonna be giving a lecture on
the secrets of pons and I actually
misread the lecture last week I assumed
it was just a regular pawn structure
lecture but I'm actually supposed to
reveal secretive things about Palmer
so I'm actually gonna try to do that
this week so I'll let you in secrets
that only pawns know about and a select
few grandmasters so this was actually a
game of mine I played Chicago Open of
last year against and I am Guillermo
Vasquez and most of you know every game
has kind of emotions that you kind of
remember with it like ah this game I was
really depressed cuz I had some bad
position this game was you know just
crazy this game I felt really confident
this game I remember I didn't know
whether I was gonna win lose or draw for
most of this game so for but for me this
was just a fun game to play I had
already lost early in the tournament
iPad chances to play for first but
really you know I didn't have super
strong ambitions at this point and I
just had a lot of fun playing this game
so I like to show games I had fun
playing just because I think it makes
the lecture less newsworthy so d4 it's
what I've been playing these days mostly
Catalan it's been one of my staples in
the past bunch of years take C 496 this
is one of the more ambitious lines I
would say where black tries to actually
hold on to the pawn I don't want to get
into too much theory because this game
is quite long and I want to get through
it
castles rook b8 Knight c3 b5 so I used
to study with Grand Master Jessie cry
it's kind of a fun guy and he nicknamed
this line the barbarian line for the
very reason that it's extremely greedy
black is basically saying look I'm not
gonna develop I'm just going to defend
my C pawn my structure is kind of loose
and he's basically saying and you got
nothing I just have an extra pawn you
don't have much of anything so white has
to play very actively here so just to
warm you guys up what kind of move do
you think white should look for eat for
eat for is a very typical move in these
kind of positions in this particular
position e4 is not considered the most
accurate the drawback of a move like 'if
or even though it looks very nice is
sometimes you block your bishop and
other times you allow a night before
with ideas of 93 I doubt that e4 is some
awful move here but it's not it's not
really considered the main move but it
is a very typical one so b3 also very
typical you have to be careful though if
you allow b4 followed by C 3 I'm not
saying that you don't get anything but
you have to be that's a big that's like
protected past pawn so if you allow
protected passed pawn you need something
really strong in response but otherwise
yeah b3 is a very typical move here but
there's another move which is 95 yes it
is that's the main move here so I mean
we're all still in theory that's an
excellent question Knight takes d4 what
is white - yes and here black has a
problem because you're just gonna take
this Knight and if the knight moves
Bishop c6 might be interesting too but
the easiest of course is trading Queens
and now you have a choice you can take
this rook but probably it's better to
actually take the B a row because then
you don't even get trapped and as a
general rule I like to take the more
active piece not the passive piece you
could call it a Josh rule probably most
people would take this b8 rook as well
but okay so the main move here is Knight
takes e5 pawn takes e5 and this is a
kind of an interesting moment and
I'd say a fairly common one there's a
chance for black to trade Queens now
normally when you're up up material and
trying to face initiative trading Queens
is a good thing right but here I don't
like Queen takes d1 as a move if you
guys have any ideas as to why that would
be do you guys know why Queen takes d1
might not be the best move yeah
because you'd like to trade Queens when
you're getting attacked right yeah so
you can play knight back here you can
give back the pawn but then you're gonna
be a bit worse and now Bishop c6 and all
of a sudden you may not win material
immediately after this but what's blacks
problem here Bishop e3 so Bishop a7 Zona
but let's even say you don't even have
Bishop e7 mr. Bay 7
Black has almost no moves here so even
if you don't want to play Bishop a7 I
honestly like it for example a black
place here ok this is a terrible move
because the rook takes D 7 but I
wouldn't even take this rook I would
just you know build my position because
black has no moves so basically if your
opponent has no moves you only cash in
when you can take all their pieces if
you just take a little bit of material
don't do it you want to make sure they
stay paralyzed but the point is this is
just way to put too much of a parallel
paralyzing idea
so instead black plays here and you'll
find this is common that sometimes when
the Queens go you still have an
initiative you still have attacking
ideas sometimes trading Queens actually
does not help the defender and this is
definitely the case so here a move like
Bishop c6 isn't gonna work because you
can even I think play a six maybe b4 is
a move as well I don't know and then
Bishop b7 and you're just not in time I
trade off your active Bishop and you end
up down upon so there are a few moves
I've played Bishop f4 myself here and I
remember winning this game but I got
into some trouble so I didn't really
want to repeat it
and of course in this game this is all
theory but my recollection of theory was
already kind of hazy this is not a line
I face very often it's not an excuse but
it is an explanation okay fine it's an
excuse in any case I play Queen t4 which
I knew was the main move black plays c5
Queen f4 so rather than defend the pawn
to Bishop you defend it with the Queen
at first it looks kind of weird Bishop
f4 looks a lot more natural but what's
the advantage of having the Queen on f4
it's active anything else
it's out of the way of perhaps which
piece right so the rook can now go to d1
and it really does follow kind of an
image of its rule which is he always had
like if you have a like a certain side
where you're better just kind of put
your Queen over there and it's kind of a
nice rule because the queen is a very
annoying piece especially if you're
playing for initiative so black played
Queen c7 so I need a way to continue my
initiative right if I let black take the
five pawn or if I let black do anything
himself it's going to be kind of
unpleasant so what do I do
probably not so you got to keep
attacking rook do you one's possible but
what exactly is the plan I don't know
I mean luck doesn't have to take
immediately black can play a move like
Bishop e7 as well just trying to get
castled taking this pawn always has some
kind of risks to it not that it's
necessarily a bad move but uh you always
have to be a little careful while taking
this pawn say you take with the Knights
first of all taking with the Queen would
actually lose why is that tactics
tactics yes indeed Queens hanging
exactly so there are always tactics
Knight takes pawn you may be run into a
four there's a chance you can be okay
here but this looks a little flimsy
right maybe a six you can try to hold on
but honestly it's probably gonna be kind
of tough there are occasions where I
actually have dreams and they often
usually are just dreams of sacking my
queen and playing Bishop c6 check and
rook a7 and going after the king but
probably this is a little too much
although after a move like Bishop f4 I
don't think this position is actually
that clear no no I wish I wish no this
this is my dream this is this is not an
almost never a reality I actually did
get to sack my queen in one Catiline but
there were no pawn secrets in that game
so I can't show it okay I played a4
immediately I wanted to play and he
played a6 my impression during the game
was that this is too slow but probably
not so bad I took
and rook t1 so now that I've loosened up
his pawns I'm more okay playing a move
like rook e1 it's pretty similar but now
I've he's committed to playing a6 he
gave my rook an open file so like to me
keep in mind I didn't think he'd play a
six I thought he would play another move
maybe before even takes a four is
actually quite playable there but the
point is that I wanted to secure mope
and file for my rook as soon as I could
to me that was more active and more
accurate than rook t1 I don't know this
is actually true you might be right
maybe the moves are pretty similar but I
wanted to get an A for when I had the
chance so 90 85 is certainly a move what
would you guys do now sock the Queen I
like it I'm only half joking that Queen
sac is potentially quite nasty but I
think I had a much simpler idea now I
think I had something rather simple in
minds it's been a while so I have to
recall it but yeah there are a few
interesting lines I think what I was
looking at during the game was just
playing rook e8 saying look I'm gonna
trade off you're one active rook and
then all your pawns are gonna be very
loose so for example if rook takes a8
can probably throw this move in right
Queen goes back somewhere I don't know
take the rook so I just want my pawn
back and I still have an initiative
right sometimes you don't have to be
that fancy you don't have to be like oh
I'm gonna just rip you open and sack all
my pieces it's fun to do that but there
are occasions may be simpler is better I
don't know if this is actually the most
accurate but I don't know maybe black
can play a move like f6 here and claim
that I have too many pieces hanging
are you just hmm any case Bishop e7 was
played which is a kind of a more human
move just trying to get developed
so I played queen g4 trying to get some
initiative and black plays King f8 it's
possible to play it moves like g6 here
but now usually I'm very happy to just
hang this pawn and play here and it's
just kind of an annoying position a
little bit for black because even like
say you play Knight takes e5 now and I
play here what is your move you just tie
it up here Bishop g7 the threats it's
just kind of unpleasant so even though
blacks up to pawns now the initiative is
increased so one of the things you have
to do if you're playing a position like
this is black as make sure your opponent
doesn't have an avenue in make sure your
opponent doesn't have like a clear way
to improve so King f8 looks like a
strange move but it also keeps my pieces
out makes life a little bit more
annoying yeah so here actually we have a
main a big decision the main line
actually doesn't include a six a six is
actually not the main line but here I
had a major decision to make and this is
often what happens you have a double at
position there's by no means as white
worse here white is actually doing quite
well but often the way it works is in
these positions is if you play one
inaccurate move then you are worse
because this is what I want to talk to
you about this pawn clump and this is
part of the whole secret life of pawns
thing what can you guys tell me about
this pawn clump there what why we
c5 pawn I think almost all of blacks
pieces except the king in this Bishop
defend not gay it's defended by
everything how can it be weak
I have nothing attacking this remember
weaknesses this is something which I
know probably you guys have heard but
weaknesses are only weaknesses if they
can be attacked if they can't be
attacked it's not by no means a weakness
and it's one of the steps kind of people
have to take towards becoming like
stronger players 2,000 2,200 2,400 it's
that just because a pawn could be weak
doesn't mean it is right you know a
backward pawn is even a backward pawn
something like that we can define we
know as a weakness or an isolated pawn
if nothing can attack that pawn it is
not a weakness
you could argue in the long term it
might become one but that's a completely
different thing so in this case the c5
pawn in particular I would not call a
weakness it's defended by everything and
it's also potentially shielded by this
pawn so I hate to actually completely
disagree with you but I'd say this is
actually blacks least weak pawn I would
say this and this maybe you could argue
a weak but I still need a way to attack
them but here's what I would say about
these pawns do you think that in the
middle game they're a particularly
strong force exactly for now they cannot
move
they cover lots of squares which makes
them pretty strong but they're not
deadly the problem is if I allow an
endgame if I allow the position to
simplify these pawns are massive in the
endgame these pawns are just monstrous
completely monstrous and we do get there
so you'll see how annoying these pawns
are but you have to realize in the long
term these pawns are extremely strong so
you have to resist simplification of
anything at all costs
let's take White's pawn structure so I
have an extra pawn on the Kings side but
obviously they're doubled what do you
guys think about this pawn structure
that's true I mean I would say okay this
is extremely solid but what about this
pawn I don't mean immediately I mean in
the law when I talk about pawn structure
I don't just mean for this move right I
didn't just discuss these pawns on this
exact move
discussed them for the course of the
game what they mean so let's say here
like a five pawn is definitely a
weakness right so my question is does
white want to play the move f4 I see a
bunch of head shakes which I like why is
that mm-hmm yeah so you'll play this
move if you have to f4 it's kind of one
of those moves where you only want to
play it if you absolutely must but the
problem is that you really don't want to
have to because it blocks your pieces it
blocks your Queen kind of it kills your
initiative in some ways so f4 is not a
move you want you look forward to so I
had a major choice here I actually I
think I thought for about 30 minutes on
this move this was a really difficult
choice and my options were actually had
for Bishop f4 f4 queen h5 and Bishop g5
a lot of options only one move let me
put it this way one move leads to a
slight advantage every other move is bad
so I'm gonna put the pressure on you
guys only I'm not giving you half an
hour I could do that and I'm just snooze
the rest of the lecture but I decided
I'll give you guys a minute maybe so you
don't have time to calculate everything
I'm not giving it to you i I calculated
for 30 minutes I didn't even come close
to calculating everything now maybe that
means I need to work on my calculation I
would not argue with that
but it's also just a really complicated
position so what I would say is all
right this is gonna be a gril cliche
what does your heart tell you there's
actually a student of mine who actually
says this
hmm which one looks passive vision ref
for indeed looks passive and Bishop f4
has a very big problem with it to
potentially black has a very annoying
move here no f6 is the opposite of an
inline move that's like ah please play
f6
yeah because f6 of course it takes and
the bishop too strong it is and I don't
think my queen has a happy home if I go
here maybe Bishop b7 sometimes maybe
even g5 it looks weird but my pieces are
getting completely tangled here this
looks insane but what is what am i doing
well if Queen h3 you get your Queen trap
yeah that's why I'm not going there if
this move then g5 and now you're
threatening the bishop and also g4 which
would be very unfortunate and
embarrassing
so Bishop f4 just does not work here if
I have to move my bishop back say here
Knight takes pawn this is just getting
very ugly right again this looks like it
could become maybe weaknesses it could
be that this king is weak but I need a
way to attack it I need my pieces to be
good and they're not so it's kind of the
same concept it's really like this is
only like blacks Kings only weak if I
can actually do anything and right now
my pieces are a mess there is no way I
can't take advantage of this so Bishop
f4 I do not like Queen h5 s what I
played in the game but unfortunately
that was not best F forest lane so the
key is Bishop g5
and I just I could not calculate the win
here or calculate the really strong
lines and that's kind of why I didn't
play it there's a particular idea I'd
missed which I'll show you guys in any
case I'll show you a sample variation so
the idea is that you're trading off the
two bishops now you might think why
would you want to trade when you're
playing for the initiative normally you
don't but why why is trading these
bishops such an important thing exactly
so speaking of pawns if I can trade
these bishops and even play f4 then that
changes the whole outlook doesn't it
because then I can plunk a knight on d6
and ask black how he feels about life
all right
so trading these bishops not to mention
this pawn becomes weak trading these
bishops kills a lot of blacks defensive
ideas so strategically it's something I
want to do so if I thought that black
just had to trade I would have just done
this but I was worried about this but it
turns out after this trade I play Queen
e4 I think I was mainly focused on Queen
f4 and I couldn't find anything but this
is what I missed Queenie for Queen c7
and I have a particularly strong idea
here
and this is what I missed
very nice
again the rookie a move is the key and
the reason why is this rook glues the
whole position together and this is a
very common thing when you have a king
that's not castled and a rooks that
cannot connect you if you trade off the
active rook usually that's when your
opponent experiences problems this is a
very common pattern but I for some
reason I just my mind was right I was
wrapped around Queen afore so much I
didn't consider Queen e4 which looked
weird to my eyes but if I had spent a
little bit more time I don't say more
time I spent 30 minutes if I had focused
a little more on these lines knowing
Bishop g5 is what I wanted to do I maybe
could have made a better decision
because this position is actually quite
bad for black rook takes b8 Knight takes
b5 is threatened f5 is extremely
weakening if I go Queen f4 then this
this pin is very nasty so yeah I mean
this is just a very very dangerous
position for blood in any case I
unfortunately played here so Queen h5
and my idea was that now if ever takes
here Bishop goes here and I'm preventing
blacks h5 idea but he actually came up
with a clever idea here Queen takes e5
as possible and now I believed I was
going to trade and play Bishop f4 and
what do you do now well Bishop f6 you
lose your rook so I wouldn't recommend
it
f6 probably and I think even just rook a
7 so it's kind of like our other
situation I think actually you've traded
Queens but I don't think it actually
helped your defense ok quite possible I
might even take your Knights takes
and here I don't know if I want to play
Bishop c6 first probably I like how I
don't want to trade rooks now look at
this guy it's a monster trading the
rooks was good when I was really focused
on this weakness now I want to keep your
king bad I'm actually just playing
against your king I'm not playing
against like like trying to win a pawn
here but the idea of this is that now
you may be up material but you're up
even two pawns but look at this King
look at this rook I don't know maybe
maybe this is okay for black but at
least from a practical standpoint I
think this is kind of scary to play so
yeah I don't know if all this was
completely accurate but I would say that
was in general mind yeah but he found
actually a very clever move he played
this so what do you think his idea is so
with this one move he plugs up one of
his weaknesses so now if he plays g6 I
have a problem so this move I was not
happy to see so I played f4 not happily
but I thought the alternative was well I
just lose my pawn for nothing so this
was kind of a an interesting decision he
I thought he would play g6 here which
might be more accurate he'd went for b4
right away which by itself is probably
not so bad here but now black has a big
choice black could play Bishop d7
or black could play g6 and then Bishop
d7 essentially one of these lot moves is
extremely inaccurate and let would let
me actually take the initiative back so
my question for you guys is which move
would you play it should be 7 or g6 I
mean that's a good idea but I should
rephrase my question basically black has
two choices play Bishop d7 and then g6
or g6 and then Bishop e7 both moves are
coming
okay but I'm not obligated to go to F in
the game actually didn't go there in my
game I'll tell you my idea was actually
at least I thought it was clever maybe
it wasn't clever but my idea was to play
Queen h3 Knight d6 and then I can take
what the Queen and get my Queen back in
yeah anyway I play for the small
miracles the small miracles
well yeah after g6 yeah as you said even
after Queen h3 King g7 it's a very good
position for black Bishop d7 is also
good he played this one and I was very
sad I missed my chance here to be fair
it was actually quite complicated but I
had a chance to actually take the
advantage here I can but do you have a
particular idea of say it's okay say say
I played g6 it's an interesting move
actually creates three try to remember
what I saw here I thought you might just
play rookie aide and trade me off
ah I see yeah I don't think well take C
5 is not a good move this is check but
you have Knight f6 yeah and this is
quite good for you so yep
rook a it's a very poor move rook a son
I don't remember looking at this maybe I
should have maybe this is a move I
should have looked into Queen see it
nice yeah maybe Queen c8 as possible
because Queen b6 I didn't trust at all D
so maybe I'm not sure I mean I've takes
here I can take with the rook and
probably I'm okay right so the only way
you're gonna punish this is by taking on
d7 and it's possible there's just not
enough here cuz Queen a1 is a nice nasty
tempo move right so I'm not sure you
actually have enough here this is this
is very good question though because
this I I don't think I even saw this so
this was bad on my part to not calculate
this but yeah Queen a1 is a very
annoying move right because that's gonna
force you back but very good question I
mean this this cookie seven move was
definitely move that escaped me here I
will admit but I actually have a very
strong move here and it's to do with
pawns shockingly I know I know you
didn't expect that I like to surprise my
audience f4 is such an unfortunate move
for what reason in particular it blocks
my bishop yes I do
I wish so f5 and the bishop can now come
to f4 and this king is open I have to
admit I think I was half asleep this
game for at least some of it because I
don't know how I did not look at have
five carefully but the actual variation
is very complicated I'll show it you
guys to it it's pretty awesome actually
so black takes Queen takes and again
black has different move orders they can
try they can allow me to take on e6 but
allowing me to take any six is clearly
risky right yeah like black can try to
take this pawn with the night but after
pawn takes pawn pawn takes pawn or f6 it
just looks horrible right so at the very
least it's not a very human thing to do
and I wouldn't have to calculate any
further if I black has to allow me to
take on e6 I know this is my right move
right there's no way I can get better
than being able to take on e6 here
especially considering here I was
looking at just having a bad position
close to lost maybe so the fact that I'm
allowed to play f5 I should have really
but the line that worried me I think was
takes takes takes I saw Bishop f4 f6
but here I just could not find a way to
break through luckily you guys can
mm-hmm yeah here I thought I was stuck
but I am NOT stuck yes
little slow I need something quick right
rooty seven Quinte XD 7 boom
so yeah politics is very weakening and
it kind of it allows similar lines so
we'll just focus on Bishop takes for now
because this is the more obvious move I
trade and now one move is extra inning
here but only one move I would be
careful if I were you
so this is the example I think what
you're doing here is you see a way to
win a rook right but what have you
sacrificed I would actually not be so
happy about winning this rook you could
take the other rook too but what is the
problem you have now Kings a little weak
but also what did I say about these
pawns in the endgame and later in the
game imagine if we trade Queens and
you're trying to win this pawn in the
endgame these pawns are monstrous and
this is the danger you have in positions
like this if you cash in at the wrong
moment you end up with just an awful
position because these pawns are way too
strong so it looks really tempting to
win the exchange it's I even winning a
rook cuz you're already done a piece so
I understand you have to make sure if
you cash in for not enough you're gonna
end up in trouble right because those
pawns are just way too strong and we
could discuss exchange sacks for you
know for ten classes but basically often
being that up the exchange is not as
great as you know we once thought
ruk t5 is possible so I'm not exactly
sure what happens now
he could be Queen f7 I'm worried about
allowing rook e8 check
probably can't do that right so I don't
know maybe this wouldn't a piece back
but the problem is that winning the
piece back may not actually lead to a
win right because I'm already down some
material so I don't know I mean it looks
very strong yeah to be fair this is
totally a computer position I'm not even
gonna pretend this is me the movies are
okay six but this is the point you're
not just trying to win a piece you're
trying to actually go for checkmate
you're trying to go after blacks King
because think about it if black ever
gets it right these pawns are just
killers but these pieces are very bad
and then the key idea is you're
threatening rook takes f6 which is just
a monster move right because then you
win material but you also keep your
initiative and that's the key and if
black plays here you have a really
really nice move again ooh
threatening this threatening this this
would have been quite spectacular but of
course I wasn't paying attention enough
for I was half asleep at the wheel I
don't know hope I don't drive like that
anyway in the game I played Knight d6
mmm I think blacks better now not lost
I'm not lost but I think blacks better
that's topper I mean like lay put it
this way when I looked at this position
after the game I didn't even have the
computer on I'm like why didn't I play a
5 here and then I turn on a computer
computer spitting out all this random
garbage which I'm not necessarily gonna
see but at the same time f5 is just such
a nice move it opens up blacks King it
gets my Bishop out it just solves so
many problems with my position after
black plays g6 you can see the problems
of my position right I just I can't do
anything and in the long term these
pawns are just gonna kill me so it's one
of those things where my intuition
screaming for f5 but it doesn't mean I
can see all the variations or even that
I'd just play it immediately like there
are times you have to kind of see it if
you don't see it and you end up just
down tons of pawns it's not really that
fun right but let me put it this way if
I had been more astute I would have
calculated f5 and really pushed for it I
honestly thought that black would just
play g6 immediately here and I think I
assumed the position would transpose so
I just wasn't looking hard enough so you
guys want to make sure you don't make my
mistake you really want to look for your
chances especially when your position is
kind of depressing and you're not sure
where your cano player will come from so
I played 96 I think I was also half
hoping he'd take here without thinking
yes the the GM secret thinking has been
revealed I hope for me I hope for mating
1 unfortunately he played g6 and I was
wrong
but ok Queen back to Age 3 this was my
idea takes takes Bishop takes d6 and I
think here maybe Bishop takes d6 wasn't
the best actually he maybe could have
lived with that Knight a little bit but
I don't know I mean it's easy to say
that now but that's a pretty annoying
night so he took it here and now we come
kind of to the second phase of the game
which was actually very interesting so I
play d4 black played Knight f6 and here
I have a major choice to make luckily
this one I did make correctly I can play
either a5 or f5 and only someone who
truly understands the secret of pawns
will know which move to make
we have one vote for f5 without really
what are the rest of you thing look 85
creates this massive massive pawn chain
look at that pawn chain you could kill
someone with that punching I like the
way you guys are thinking too many
people I think get too obsessed with
purely the pawns they see e5 they see
that massive pawn chain they're like man
I could like swing that around do a
Bruce Lee thing with that pawn chain
that's amazing
the problem is all you have is that pawn
chain black plays Queen takes g2 I was
actually worried about even 95 keeping
the Queens on because I thought my king
was actually worse than blacks but okay
either one and then as we can see what
do you do here you have no active plan
whatsoever Black's gonna play for c3
what am i doing I have this beautiful
pawn chain Congrats to me but what else
right and this is the problem I'm still
down upon these pawns as we know
potentially disaster for me looming and
I need something to do so I like that
you guys really were not tempted by this
f5 breaking up black spawns opening up
blacks King right and also letting out
what peace my depressed poor bishop
which would have been really sad if I
play d5 is now jumping up and down gets
to run run out wreak havoc on blacks
position so this was the key moment
after E 5 my positions quite bad but I
think after f5 I have at least counter
play I would actually take white and a
lot of these positions but it's unclear
it's hard for me to give a pure
evaluation so black took so here I was
actually optimist about my chances maybe
too optimistic but my opponent played
well now he took got the Queen's off and
played King g7 he was not tempted to
take this palm after which I go here
and now I have Bishop e5 I have d7 he
knew that this was not what he wanted
something like this for example would be
quite unfortunate and now rook a6 yeah
blacks not White's not blacks not gonna
get to move for the next century so it's
gonna be very bad but my opponent of
course was no fool he played here
I played Bishop f4 97 and here I was
really excited I'm like I have the
initiative but I underestimated a part a
part of blacks position any guess of
what that is the pawns you cannot
underestimate these pawns in the endgame
these are nasty so even though I have
the nice minor piece even though my
rooks are nice and active I have to be
very very careful here and I think I
actually played some poor moves
not because I was calculating horribly
or anything like this but because I
underestimated blacks pawns and in their
long-term potential
so I played takes and rook a 7 which of
course can't be bad and here I sort of
started to realize things weren't so
easy but it was still I still wasn't
totally sure what to do probably I
should play g4 and kind of get my own
pawns going that's what I played which
looked completely normal but black has a
very strong idea one which my opponent
found very quickly he played this phase
of the game extremely well
because this looks so nice right I
attacked two pawns i won I mean well not
two pawns I once but I'm attacking this
I'm attacking this I'm all set right
but there's actually a problem here
rookie I don't know the problem is now I
take this rook I take here I'm
threatening rookie 7 check I'm
threatening this pawn it's a lot of
threats right probably you don't know
allow that no the e pawn is actually
extremely important
this is a very strong move it's not just
to get out of the pin it's that I keep
myself from coming in here and this was
the moment where it dawned on me wait a
second wait a second position is not so
easy because first of all this rook move
which wasn't a bad move by any means it
was just a forcing move it was natural
this rooks actually completely misplaced
now it's hitting this knight but so what
so I take the pawn what else can I do no
black could maybe play rook a8 which
might be even a little bit stronger but
okay black play d5 which is a very
natural move and this is another very
nice move so I understand rook e8 had
some potential concretely but II five
positionally at least is a beautiful
move because what is black gonna do next
King e6 and look at these pieces this
pawn for these pawns may look weird but
they're very effective they keep blacks
King completely secure this pawn
remember one this pawn I thought was a
strength is it a strength now now it's
just gonna now it's just gonna fall
almost at any time in fact the funny
thing is that black in a lot of
positions doesn't want to take it
because then my rook can get active
so black actually wants to leave me with
this pawn put the King on e6 and my I
have connected passers right
congratulations to me what's the problem
with these passers why they're far
they're slow these these are not rabbits
they do not hop up the board real fast
so whereas I have these pawns just
looming over my head like a cloud it's
just not it's not fun so here I was like
oh alright I have to be very careful
so I played h4 gotta get my pawns going
right okay so first of all black could
blunder Bishop check but he didn't he
played King e6 rook e8 I still was kind
of worried about and now I've actually
found a move I was very proud of now
maybe I experienced pride way too often
but I was very happy with this move
because it basically it gives black a
chance to force a draw but I thought
that I was
one who's in trouble here and when you
realize that sometimes it means you have
to make that tough decision being okay
you know what I have to allow for straw
but what else can I do
and this isn't the only move here but if
I let black first of all if h5 rook h8 I
just lose my pawn right g4 is very slow
and if I let black play rook e8 next
bring the rook down here I am NOT gonna
be happy right remember once these pawns
start to roll I'm just in big trouble
this is what I played here yes so I play
Bishop g7 but it means I had to
surrender myself to the idea that after
rook g8 I have to take the pawn and what
do you think the evaluation is here I'm
probably not gonna win I have two
connected passers but black has these
horrific nightmare of pawns and even if
c3 takes takes just because I have Black
has doubled pawns that doesn't mean that
I'm better here it means that because I
mean think about it blacks pawns are
more advanced black has a better King
than I do and these things often
outweigh the pawn structure so event I
can convey something to anyone about
pawns it's that it's not always about
the pawn structure it's the pieces that
accompany them if if blacks getting the
rooks in if the pawns are really far
advanced if my King is not as good as
black super active King that's going to
matter more than Oh black has doubled
pawns and I have connected once so it's
important not to get caught up in that
but luckily this was where my opponent
decided to go a little bit of stray
black played c3 not by itself such an
awful move yep I take but now I don't
have to play Bishop e5 this was my other
idea oh this is kind of funny it's like
Bishop g7 looks so harmless right but if
I get an H 6 h7 that Bishop is gonna
look a lot better right so here black
still had a chance black could have
played rugby too rook b8
ah I think black actually has to try to
draw now that's the key and this is the
other thing about the position remember
that moment where I realized wait I
shouldn't be trying to win I should be
trying to draw if I hadn't at that
moment I might have just lost right
black needed to have that same moment he
had to be like wait a moment Bishop g7
h5 I need to make sure I draw
so black had to play active with the
rooks rook b1 by the way is a very nasty
idea now so so I actually if I want to
try to do anything I need to play this
move can't play here but most likely
after something like Knight f6 probably
going to be Josh h5 hangs of h6 I'm not
really threatening anything yeah this is
probably the best but it's a little too
reduced I'm probably gonna lose one of
these pawns King g5 I think is a decent
move now it's just to reduce like
there's not enough material for me to
try to win prolly not saying this is
like I agree to a draw right away but
most likely this should be drawn with
best play but black still had to try
this instead black played rook g8 well
you're running out of options now this
is a very annoying combo all of a sudden
right so black really didn't have too
much better he probably shouldn't take
but it's already very dangerous for
black I think no now I'm playing for a
win but this is the thing like people
asked me where you're trying to win this
game we trying to draw this game I'm
just trying to play good moves I don't
care if a draw is the best result I can
hope for cuz I have a bad position
whatever but you have to be alert if
your opponent gives you chances you know
don't don't be like well I can never win
this game because I'm defending of
course you can win right so it's like
you kind of have to take what your
opponent gives you and this endgame is
very complicated we could go over it for
a long time we do not have that time but
basically even in this endgame the pawn
structure is really hard to handle so
this was played I took and this is where
I realized something
here's my question for you how should I
approach this position now
should I try to hold on to this pawn and
try to push it through what should I do
very nice that's the move I played and
again I'm not sure it's necessary but if
I allow 95 to d3 why should I be better
there maybe I don't know Black has nice
pawns Black has a better King
I'm always looking at King as you guys
know but when I play rook a7 I'm saying
look you can have my pawn but your
Knights never moving remember the
paralysis thing I was telling you guys
about that if you can keep your opponent
paralyzed it's often very good so I play
rook c4 i lure the king up I play back
slight improvement to my rook I think
black gives up and takes I play King f2
and now even though I'm only only have
one pawn left because black completely
tied up and these pawns are separated
they're not together it's gonna be very
difficult for black to do much so I'd
love to say I won this without further
problems but it doesn't ever seem to
happen black played King e6 I played rip
d1 keeping an eye on the night so the
idea is that if black tries to check me
this nights gonna hang after takes he
doesn't have time hmm King here
yeah I'm not gonna take the pawn don't
you worry I could have played g4 here
but I decided to be more patience yeah
and here I got a little sloppy with g5
if I play rook a7 and chase try to take
the pawn next after I move my rook say
it's it would be a little easier I
decided on this which is still winning
but this was a little bit challenging so
I did this I can't go this way cuz black
keeps checking me so I decided all right
at this point we both had less than 5
minutes so it was very challenging so
this is a win because eventually I
should be able to dislodge this King but
it's a very tricky win and if you have
no time winning this is really really
tough but the
is do not be in a hurry have a clear
plan my plan is to get rid of this king
right but once you and try to go for
that plan but don't feel like you have
to accomplish it right away
take your time move back and forth
occasionally build up your time if it's
30 second increment do not try to play
at all just all the most complicated
lines when you have two seconds left and
here I thought I did an okay job but it
turned out after the game I played one
inaccurate move so I did this so my plan
is basically to get my King enforced
this rook over and eventually bring my
king in this way just to share with you
guys I leave my rook here so this Knight
can't move I leave my rook here so this
pawn can't be captured but here I got a
little sloppy I should play King D 3 and
then King back
and then here and then go forward like
normal I played here and now black out
of the draw
that he missed but you guys will
discover rooks e4 does not draw I mean
you can take my rook if you want well
first of all I don't have to take you
but even if I take 93 King takes here I
highly doubt you're gonna draw that my
King's awfully close yeah that's not a
girl for sure
yeah I missed this idea yeah I missed
this move in time pressure so I have to
go here and allow takes but then of
course it should be drawn although he
can't take immediately because of rook-a
for like he has to be a little tricky
about it like well maybe rook takes is
still playable no then check in here oh
there was some weird way he could take
this pawn now but okay we're okay one is
super tricky but after takes the problem
is I can't go king d4 cousin I have
three so next black just plays king g6
Knight back night here ah all my work
luckily neither of us at any time so he
didn't spot it either he played back hmm
I thought after I moved I think and I
was like oh oh that's usually the way it
works you see it after you move so
eventually I got my King in and now I
should be winning and I just wanted to
show one last position I played here and
he resigned but instead of resigning he
could have played one last try which is
to play rook f6 check so the question is
how should I win here there was one very
dangerous pitfall which I don't want to
say I almost fell into cuz I don't think
I would have played this but I didn't
see it was a pitfall during the game for
sure I know what I would have played
here but rook f5 is actually a very bad
move let me show you
kingi four wins because I'm gonna just
check on h5 check on g5 black's dead
right that's way too strong if he checks
here I'd block with the rook but I I
don't think I would've done this but
after Knight rook here which looks like
it's winning tactically well if you
played g8 Queen the night check-in takes
so here and at first I thought this was
just winning but black of course has
which move
indeed and takes upon yeah and then take
the pawn I could try rook f7 but then it
is a draw with the best play so I guess
the only last lesson is if you're black
here especially if you need their view
of time later got six check what's the
worst that happens that for King e4 you
resign but do not resign that move too
early because again especially with no
time I don't I would not have played
this King e4 was my plan but just cuz I
thought it was easier but Brooke f5
would be an easy pitfall to go into
right so give your opponent one last
chance to not win losing my advice
anyway I hope you guys enjoyed this game
and maybe know a little bit more about
masses of pawns
you